after months of waiting we finally know
how street fighter 6 plays and get this
it's an open world street fighter game
that is super wild but it's only the tip
of the iceberg when it comes to what we
know now capcom is setting out to fix
all the mistakes they made with street
fighter 5 and what they showed us last
week and this week is their first
attempt at answering the question that
everyone's been asking for years
can street fighter 6 save street fighter
all right folks before we get into the
video i want to let you know that liz is
streaming another vct and a watch party
this weekend it's the last week of the
regular season for vct and you have to
tune in so make sure to check out
twitch.tv score esports all weekend long
okay so maybe that whole saving street
fighter thing was a little overblown i
actually think that street fighter 5 is
a really good fighting game right now
but it had a terrible launch and a
first impression meant that a lot of
people swore off the game forever now
street fighter 6 is coming next year to
try to win them back so what is capcom
doing open world street fighter and it
actually looks really cool they're also
completely changing the battle system
again adding a ton of new characters and
for the warheads out there we are
finally moving past street fighter 3 in
the timeline but the most important
thing is that ken's redesign makes it
look like he lost it all on crypto and
the dude is down bad i've been hacked
all my apes gone okay let's start with
the biggest thing which also happens to
be the thing we know the least about
street fighter 6 is launching with a
seemingly large and expansive single
player mode called world tour if you
watch the trailer this is the part of
the game where a person in a hoodie runs
around metro city and punches barrels
basically this is going to be a one
player mode where you create your own
character you walk around metro city you
look for other characters to fight do
side quests maybe level up that kind of
stuff we don't really know anything else
about it beyond some of the speculation
i just told you but the fact that it
exists at all is a huge deal anyone who
played street fighter 5 when it came out
remembers that that game came out with
almost no single player content and to
this day we still don't have a lot we
have the character stories which are
cute but boring the full story mode
which is lame boring and didn't come out
until months after the game came out
survival mode which is hard and boring
and arcade mode which is
fine i guess but also didn't come out
until years later they're basically all
different flavors of playing street
fighter 5 against a cpu opponent which
is sort of what most fighting games do
for single player content mortal kombat
11 tekken 7 and guilty gear strive all
basically have movie-esque story modes
that occasionally pause to let you fight
a cpu actually strive doesn't even let
you do that it's just a very long very
silly cutscene it's been a long time
since any fighting game took single
player content seriously which is one of
the reasons world tour is so exciting to
me i don't play a lot of the
single-player modes in fighting games
when i play them but i do play a lot of
single-player games on top of loving
fighting games and i would love to have
a reason to turn on street fighter 6
even when i don't feel like getting my
ass handed to me online and more
importantly i know that just jumping
straight into online play is something
that is really intimidating for a new
player so having a single player mode
that can help you grow and learn to play
the game or even never play online is
probably going to make new players
interested in getting involved look if
street fighter wants to grow if fighting
games in general want a big infusion of
new blood we need to find ways to bring
new players into this genre we love and
single player content seems like a
pretty good hook to do that but the
thing that matters after they finish the
single player content is whether or not
the fighting system is fun and i think
capcom has built something really
interesting here so like every street
fighter game there is a new set of
systems that replaces the previous
game's signature mechanics the
controversial v system is gone replaced
by a new set of mechanics called drive
when a round starts in street fighter 6
you'll have a full drive gauge which you
can spend on a bunch of mechanics from
previous street fighter games one bar
gets you drive impact an armored move
that blows up your opponent's attacks
sort of like focus attacks from street
fighter 4. holding down middle punch and
middle kick will put you in drive parry
which parries attacks while draining
drive meter if you tap the two buttons
right before an attack hits you you'll
get a perfect parry instead which looks
like it functions a lot like street
fighter 3's parries you also get meter
back and probably some other advantages
for hitting a perfect parry instead of
holding the buttons down this mechanic
has actually proven to be a bit
controversial already big names like
daigo and mago have spoken out about how
they think parries will make the game
less fun
okay there are
but to be fair we don't know exactly how
parries work yet or how they'll affect
the game's meta you can also spend your
drive meter to overdrive any special
move which works basically like ex moves
did in every game since 3 it just costs
drive instead of super meter you can
also dash cancel a parry or a cancelable
normal attack for different costs of
drive meter it works a lot like focus
pack dash cancels did in street fighter
4 which is something i know a lot of
people are excited to see back the
mechanic was really popular even though
it was a little bit broken at times
because it offered a lot of creativity
and flexibility when you were doing
combos also the perry dash cancels are
really cool in theory and they showed
off at least one really really awesome
application shuttley whiffs her stand
heavy punch and then ryu goes into perry
stands dash cancels and then punishes
that is really really sick and it looks
like great players are going to have a
lot of interesting challenging tools to
use to express their skills and finally
two bars lets you drive reversal which
counters your opponent while blocking
this is basically a v reversal from
street fighter 5. i've seen a lot of
people online be excited for the drive
system because they feel like it fixes a
lot of the problems that street fighter
5 had one since you start around with a
full drive meter you have access to all
the cool things your character can do
immediately this is one of the things
that made alpha 3 so beloved you don't
have to wait for the fun parts of a
round and two it's not a comeback
mechanic one of the biggest problems
people had with v-triggers in street
fighter 5 is that since you built it up
for losing health it let you steal
rounds away when you weren't winning
there were a lot of times where a player
was pretty clearly winning around until
their opponent popped v-trigger and then
they just lost randomly all right
that's what
is that what a trade
what yo what is going on
y'all yo the nuts the nuts
how do you lose that alba tree wait
that's gotta be clipped immediately the
knuckles
sometimes it was hype
but usually it just felt really bad the
other big change is how supers work
every character in street fighter 6 has
three supers but unlike in say street
fighter 3 they don't have to choose one
before they go into a round you have
access to all three supers at all times
every character can build up to three
super meters and each of their supers
cost a different amount of that meter as
an example we got to see all three of
guile supers in the newest trailer for
the game his level 1 is a super from
street fighter 5 his level 2 is his old
v trigger 1 from street fighter 5 and
his level 3 is a brand new cinematic
finisher where he stomps on his enemy
midair and then flash kicks them in the
face i think this is a really good
change i love utility supers and this
system just lets them exist i love
meteor supers because they remind me of
marvel's capcom 3 and any comparison to
that game with a good one and i just
think this is going to let characters
stand apart from each other and have
supers that aren't just long cut scenes
that do damage so new single player
content new battle system what about
online play which is probably the most
important thing street fighter 5 capcom
is promising a new online mode called
battle hub which apparently will have
new and unique ways to engage
communicate and interact street fighter
5's abysmal online play is one of the
reasons we got a community-led revolt
against fighting game developers and
publishers to give us better net code
and if street fighter 6 doesn't launch
with a functional online experience
the game may as well be dead in the
water i will say though that the little
look we did get at the battle hub makes
it look like an arxis game lobby with
little arcade machines to hang out at
and a 3d space to meet other players
this stuff has always been cute if kind
of annoying in arctis games but i do
genuinely think there's a chance here to
make an exciting place to hang out in
imagine getting to watch evo and place
best with your friends from inside
street fighter 6 or play in regular
capcom sanction tournaments that can
help qualify you for capcom cup
obviously we don't know what capcom
wants with this online mode but this
looks like what they might be going for
here gameplay aside it looks like we're
doing a sort of semi-realistic art style
for the first time which i'm not the
hugest fan of personally i think that
street fighter peaked aesthetically in
the 90s nothing they've done since alpha
3 and third strike comes close but i
also understand that my weave ass is
firmly in the minority here the street
fighter 6 engine is actually the re
engine that powered capcom's recent
resident evil remakes and those are
gritty and realistic and people loved
them so street fighter 6 is gonna inch
in that direction the animations
themselves look solid though if you let
me nerd out a little the hit stop and
key frames on each attack themselves
looks a little off in the initial
trailer it didn't look like there was
enough weight behind the attacks but
then again in the guile trailer they put
out a week later everything looked a lot
better so they're probably still
polishing the visual aspects of the game
that aside the rest of the presentation
looks really good like genuinely cool
street fighter 5 is basically fighting
simulator 2016 but this game is doing a
lot with the idea of being a game about
street fighting with a really cool
graffiti and neon aesthetic that has
shown up in basically everything we've
seen so far oh and we are also getting
capcom's favorite esports commentators
doing in-game commentary which actually
seems hype i would pay a lot of money
for a yikes commentary pack
oh he's so pringles wear your curly
mustache
oh scoop okay and now with all the stuff
from the trailers out of the way let's
talk about the leaks because this game
has been leaking like crazy first there
was a picture of a bunch of redesigns of
street fighter's core cast and it looks
at all the new characters in the game
it's unclear if this is the entire
launch roster or if some of these
characters are going to be dlc but it
was quickly followed up by a shot of ken
on some version of the character select
screen which basically confirmed this
legitimacy oh and the guile trailer i
mentioned earlier features the same
guile redesign that is in these leaks
which basically confirms them to be real
so um
sorry capcom we also got this video of
what is probably kami's level 3 super
which looks amazing
but holy [ __ ] her haircut is awful they
gave her the full karen it's so sad
other than cammy's hair though most of
the redesigns look really good i love
what they did with chun li and akuma and
aside from the hair kimmy's new look is
great everybody looks older and cooler
for the first time in literally decades
it's amazing and the new characters also
look really really cool it remains to be
seen how they'll translate to 3d but
this is a badass looking diverse cast
that really pop off the page to me
kimberly mimi and jp especially have
really fun designs but not everybody won
the redesign competition as i mentioned
earlier ken looks like a deadbeat
divorcee now and allegedly that might
not be far from the truth according to a
leak that i'm still not sure i believe
ken's wife and kid left him because he
threw everything away trying to be like
ryu and now he has no fighting spirit
and can barely do his special moves it
honestly seems so ridiculous that again
i'm not sure if it's true but if it is
then it's the most interesting thing
they've ever done with ken so maybe
it'll work look i know it sounds like
i'm surprised when i say things will
actually be cool or like i'm super
concerned when i say that maybe
something will work but you have to
understand after six years of street
fighter 5 my brain is wired for
disappointment which is why i'm really
surprised at how excited i am for this
game street fighter 5 had a really bad
first few years but the people who took
over designing the game who are the same
people who are designing street fighter
6 really turned the ship around for most
people that was too little too late but
trust me despite all of the stupid
mistakes they made early on and putting
aside the still terrible net code street
fighter 5 is a really good game and that
actually makes me hopeful i'm hopeful
that that team can carry the vision they
had for the last few years of street
fighter 5 and bring it into street
fighter 6 at launch to make it a game
that will make people love street
fighter again
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this then hit the sub
button and ring the notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock
you